now I know what the numbers are as a
percentage but I know maybe 2/3 or 3/4
of what you know about integration so
much of what you know that integration
comes from your understanding of
differentiation which makes sense right
I mean they're inverses of each other
almost okay so you know for example when
we were looking at things like the chain
rule and all the ways that it works
right the derivative of log of a
function okay function the function okay
when you learn this result it now gives
you a way to understand a whole bunch of
integrals so long as you can see them in
this format right so this is you know
reverse chain rule going back in the
other direction we get that as a result
we derive it from the regular chain rule
okay I intervention my pots works
exactly the same way except it to the
reverse often or no product rule which
is kind of why it's by parts because
it's about different parts of it just
like a product is I don't know why they
don't call it reverse product rule
well I haven't I have a theory I'll test
it out on you as we go to the questions
okay so I've been that it starts with
product rule let's write down what is
pro true okay so you have some product
of functions right and we're going to
call them U of X V of X I'm just gonna
leave out the of X because it's just
short up okay but you guys know U and V
they're functions
okay they're not variables they are
actually hold functions of X right so
the product rule states well what's the
most concise way that you could write it
you're probably really usually write it
like this I know you can do it the other
way way because um it's a psalm doesn't
matter which order it's him I do prefer
it like this because it makes it easier
to remember question rule where the
order does matter unlike here okay
that's what - notation okay but you guys
might know I'm not a huge fan of -
notation because it can be quite
ambiguous and you certainly want to
never be caught writing things like this
- don't do that
okay so ambiguous not a good idea so
therefore how could we rewrite this so
that we avoid - notation what what is
you - short for it's short for do you on
DX right we're differentiating with
respect to X aren't we so this is what
I've got V do you on DX + u DV on yes
okay what I have over here like so okay
so far so good
okay let's race now I'm gonna rearrange
this a little bit okay in order to make
the integration by parts part come out a
little clearer okay which one am I going
to get on I think I want this one on
this this V do you want DX term a bit
over here V do you okay that leaves me
with one half of the plant rule on this
side okay now I want some kind of
relationship some kind of equation that
makes a statement about integration
everything here is derivatives okay so
I'm going to take every single one of my
terms and I'm going to integrate
everything with respect to X is that
okay integrate everything with respect
to X now what do you expect this to turn
into when you integrate it if the
derivative of UV you integrate it you go
back right now I know we're going to
talk about our constant integration and
that kind of thing one of the things
that set two pi integration by parts is
that there are many different
integrations that take place the minimum
is two sometimes it's three or four okay
so rather than call this UV plus C some
constant and then have to add in another
C and a different C and all those kinds
of things I'm just going to add in the
cost of intubation right at the very end
when I'm finished okay so in fact in
this form which is going to be my
formula which you can you know put a
nice big colors and put a box around it
I'm not even going to include the
constants okay just let me do example
questions now we integrated that with
respect to X you know problems what
happens here I'm gonna write out a full
form and then we can do a bit of
canceling okay so integration with
respect to X stick your integral sign in
this is the inter your remote is called
C integrand the thing being integrated
and I'm going to integrate that with
respect to X yes no to DX is there
you'll see why in a second okay this
I'll do the same thing so I get this
integral and respect to X okay now
what's going on in here is the same kind
of thing you're used to seeing when you
have to integrate and there's some kind
of substitution involved okay
so it's really when there's a
substitution if you do
right is a change in the variable of
integration that okay so this becomes
this UV - DX is canceled hmm now this
here this is the result for integration
by parts it doesn't look like we've done
anything fancy it looks like we just
rearranged a little bit stuck some
integral signs there how is this useful
how is this like a tool to actually do
anything that we couldn't do before
okay well here's what I draw your
attention to see on this side over here
okay I know it looks like you're
integrating some function using with
respect to some variable me you can
think of it in those terms okay but
another way you can consider this is
you're integrating something and these
to remember that U and V are just
functions right so here u and DV are
also functions of some kind so what this
is telling me is I can integrate a
product u times DV right if I can work
out these and if they're any easier okay
and just so happens if we pick them
correctly often these things are much
easier to work out something like this
okay